ALEX: Welcome to this event.
Another series in the Gayglers
pride month, so happy pride
month everyone!
[APPLAUSE]
ALEX: Pride is in fact the
entire month long, and not
just one debaucherous weekend.
So it's my pleasure today
to introduce two leading
advocates in the gay civil
rights movement, Kris Perry
and Sandy Stier.
They have been at the forefront
of the Prop 8
litigation battle and we're very
honored to have them with
us here today.
They've been together since '97,
were married in 2004, and
have raised-- perhaps their
greatest achievement--
four boys together.
The two youngest ones just
graduated last weekend.
Just in time to recognize
Supreme Court decisions that
will be coming down next week.
The Supreme Court is taking
their time and is going to
roll out momentous decisions
altogether next week on gay
marriage, Voting Rights Act,
affirmative action.
So next week is going
to be very exciting.
Kris is executive director of
the First Five Years Fund,
which is a national organization
that focuses on
investments in quality early
childhood education programs
for disadvantaged children.
And Sandy, on the far right, is
a director of information
systems for Alameda County
Health Care Services Agency.
And I'm not going to tell you
too much about their story,
because they're going to do a
much better job of telling it
themselves.
So I'll hand it off
to you guys.
Thank you so much.
SANDY STIER: Thank you
for having us.
[APPLAUSE]
SANDY STIER: So first of all,
I'd like to say, if you want
to call Kris, "Perry,"
feel free.
Because she is now known as
"Perry" to the broader
community and to the media.
We're so happy to be here and to
talk to you about where we
are with the case for
marriage equality.
It's been a great journey
and an exciting one.
And we feel very privileged to
get to be in the position of
representing such an important
civil rights issue.
Today we'd like to take you
through some different parts
of the case and show you
a couple video clips.
Hopefully they'll
be interesting.
We want to use most of our time
for Q&A to hear from you
and get a better idea of what
your questions are, and what
your concerns are, and how you
view this particular case.
So starting off, we have this
picture of us in front of the
Supreme Court.
We were there in March
of this year.
The transcripts are
available online.
You can Google them
if you want to.
They're quite interesting.
We were there with our kids and
our legal team, including
Enrique Monagas, who is
here with us today.
So he's going to help field some
of the legal questions,
if you have anything
you want to ask.
And let's go ahead
and get going.
KRIS PERRY: So nothing of this
scale and scope is possible
with just a couple of people.
We're part of a really large
team, made up of funders, and
attorneys, and advocates.
What you see here before you
are just a sampling of the
people that have been
invested in this
from the very beginning.
The Reiners, Michelle and Rob
Reiner, along with Dustin
Lance Black, and Bruce Cohen
and Cleve Jones, are on the
board of the American Foundation
for Equal Rights.
And have made it their mission
to not only contribute
financially, but to help others
contribute financially.
And that, in fact, has been
one of the most important
roles in this.
A case that takes four years
to travel through the legal
system generates some legal
fees, even when people are
being generous with their time,
including pro bono.
But those board members have
done a huge amount to help
this movement.
And then above them, you can see
the other plaintiffs, Jeff
and Paul, next to Chad Griffin,
who has since moved
on to the human rights
campaign.
And our attorneys, David Boies
and Ted Olson, along with
Christina Shockey and Adam
Umhoefer, who are also some of
the founding members
of the American
Foundation of Equal Rights.
But one of more fun stories in
all of this is how did Sandy
and I actually come to be
a part of this team?
We are not Hollywood
A-listers, we are not attorneys.
And we are not long-time,
legendary, gay rights
activists like Cleve Jones.
We are, in fact, just ordinary
people that were busy raising
our families and going
to work every day.
When we learned that there was
possibly going to be a
challenge to Proposition 8.
And we learned that through our
friend, Chad Griffin, who
at the time, was working with
Rob Reiner in Los Angeles on a
number of other political
issues.
Not the least of which was early
childhood education,
which is what I have dedicated
my career toward.
And I was on a phone call with
Chad just out of the blue one
day, and he mentioned that he
was putting a group of people
together because they were
really upset about how
Proposition 8 had passed.
And I asked him a little bit
about it and he said, well,
Rob and I were at lunch with
Michelle and we were talking
about how angry we were.
And if you know the Reiners,
they tend to be rather loud.
So apparently, they
were overheard.
And they were overheard at the
polo lounge by someone that
used to be related to Ted Olson,
a former sister-in-law.
And she came over and said, you
may not believe this, but
there is someone in Washington
DC who cares about this, who
would probably help you.
And they said, who?
And she said, Ted Olson.
And they all said, really?
Ted Olson, as in "Bush
v. Gore" Ted Olson?
And they said, yes.
And that's how this all began.
Chad knew me, Chad ended
up meeting Ted.
I know Sandy.
And we ended up--
we lived together, we actually
know each other quite well--
and so really, these things came
together rather quickly,
these relationships.
And I wanted to be sure that you
understood how we ended up
in this, because we are not
like the rest of them.
ALEX: And can you walk us
through your decision making
process on that a little bit?
Because I think here we've
got a room of some young,
aspiring, perhaps future civil
rights leaders here.
And it takes a lot of courage
to put yourself in the
spotlight, put your
name on the line.
What was your decision making
process in deciding to step up
and do that?
I mean there are lots of angry
people out there, but it's
really easy to be angry
in our living rooms.
SANDY STIER: Yeah, well
we're particularly
angry, because we have--
as we said, a lot of
kids-- and so we're
mad most of the time.
It's getting better
now that they're
graduating and moving on.
But it was actually a fairly
quick and easy decision for us
on some level.
And it's really because we felt
so strongly that marriage
should be available to us and
to everybody in our country.
And that voting on our rights
just seem completely
fundamentally wrong.
So we had such a problem with
Proposition 8 being on the
ballot in the first place.
Even being part of the voting
process and it didn't make any
sense to us.
And then when we heard about
this possible legal challenge,
we both said, oh my gosh,
what a great place
to address the issue.
We have to be protected.
We're a minority, we need to be
protected from the majority.
So for us, as individuals, I
think we both came fairly
quickly to feel very supportive
of this initiative,
approaching it in this way.
In terms of the family, we
decided, between the two of
us, that we felt comfortable
moving forward.
And we believed in it.
And we thought it was the right
team, and the right
challenge, and the
right players.
And then we just went down the
row of kids and asked each one
individually, how would
you feel about it?
Because we felt strongly that if
any one of the boys didn't
feel comfortable with our being
involved in it, that we
wouldn't do it.
Because it does impact
them, as well.
Even though they're tangential,
there's no way of
getting out of the fact that
it does impact them.
And the boys were all really
very supportive.
In part, because they are
somewhat narcissistic, to be
totally honest.
What do you think about
us being in the case?
Well, that's fine, but
I need some money.
[LAUGHTER]
SANDY STIER: Like, OK.
And yeah, I believe it and I
think it's the right thing to
do, but I'm not saying that just
for you, I'm saying it
for society.
I'm like, OK, be politically
correct.
That's totally fine.
So the boys were supportive of
it and that was all we needed.
We didn't really look for
anybody else's approval, we
didn't check in with the
rest of our families.
Just our kids and each other.
And then we moved forward.
KRIS PERRY: The courage part,
though, is sometimes, you can
mistake thinking you're signing
up for something that
was more like the other
challenges had been, which is
more of an administrative
process that seemed--
actually it was still a big
leap of faith for us to be
involved in something that
would've been more about a
paper-driven driven process--
but it became a very
people-driven process.
And I feel really fortunate that
we were supported by a
group of lawyers and advocates
that really helped us move
from something more quiet to
something a little bit louder.
And I would just say to all of
you, as you go through your
lives and you find yourself in
situations where you feel that
you have not been treated
fairly, and you have not been
given protection, and you are
not in a situation that is
really acceptable to you, there
are numerous ways to
resolve that problem.
One of which is to hire lawyers
and go through the
court system.
But it is not the only way.
And, in fact, if it weren't for
years and years, decades
really, of other people standing
up, like Harvey Milk,
and Cleve Jones, and
Phyllis and Del.
And so many others fighting
back on a more political
front, or through a grassroots
advocacy, a legal challenge
would have seemed really
premature.
Or really ill-advised.
So it's really a combination
of events that lead to a
moment in time, like this,
where we know that
everything's pulling in favor
of gay marriage now.
And so much is shifting.
But it's really a rare time to
see a social movement happen
within a few years.
But it's really after
many years.
So moving past who some of the
players are and where we've
been, we wanted to talk a little
bit about what actually
happened in that trial that we
ended up being a part of.
There were many, many witnesses
for our side.
People that came to court and
said, this is why Proposition
8 is harmful and
unconstitutional.
And the witnesses really were
on the full spectrum of
experts from Yale and Harvard
and UC Berkeley and UC Davis.
And people that had been
studying sociology and
political power and on the
institution of marriage,
frankly, for their
entire careers.
They were there to testify on
behalf of our team, as well as
laypeople, like Sandy and I,
Jeff and Paul, the mayor of
San Diego, and even someone
that had been put through
reparative therapy.
So we had a great blend of real
stories from real people,
as well as witnesses from
all over the world.
The more telling piece of the
story was how few witnesses
the other side had.
And I'll let Sandy talk about
the two witnesses that the
other side had.
And just when you look at the
numbers, it comes out very
unbalanced.
SANDY STIER: Right so, there's
nothing like being on the
winning team, right?
And it was very clear in court
in no time that we were
definitely on the
winning team.
Not only did we have great
expert witnesses, but they
talked about some of those
salient arguments that could
be presented, in terms of
economics and the political
process, and how really
under-represented gays are.
And violence against gay people,
and how many different
rights are associated with
marriage, including adoption,
immigration, so many
different things.
And how important it is
to have equality.
Well, on the other side, they
really couldn't drum up any
good expert witnesses, because
there really aren't any.
The ones that they did bring
forth, number one was David
Blankenhorn, and some of you
may have heard of him.
He kind of has switched sides
since he did his testimony.
And, in fact, he
really switched
sides during the trial.
It's an unusual thing.
And you're going to see a little
bit of that in a second
in one of these clips.
His expertise, even though he
ran an organization for
pro-traditional family, his
expertise was actually
Victorian wood cabinetry.
And that's where he had
peer-reviewed articles,
Victorian wood cabinetry, but
unfortunately, you can't
really take the knowledge from
Victorian wood cabinetry
making and apply it to equal
rights or family structure.
So that was a very awkward
situation for them.
And then the other person that
they brought forth actually
had to be subpoenaed to be
involved in the trial, because
after his deposition
with David Boies--
which is not a fun experience
in anyone's life.
I can assure you that having
David Boies depose you, would
be incredibly difficult.
He is like a surgeon
in a courtroom, if
that makes any sense.
And you actually almost felt
empathic for witnesses that
testified in ways that you
didn't agree with.
I started to feel empathy for
them, because it would be so
difficult to be on the stand
with David Boies.
KRIS PERRY: They did have two
witnesses who tried really
hard, and it was an interesting
day when
they were up there--
days.
But what's great about the case,
so for, we'll look at
the next slide, is that even
though we were there in argue
for our due process and equal
protection rights and how Prop
8 violated both of
those things.
I feel like it's hard to
synthesize a three week trial
into some simple concepts.
But for the purpose of moving
through this quickly and
helping you understand where the
primary arguments centered
around, due process and equal
protection were both.
And we felt that the witnesses
made the case that marriage is
a fundamental right.
That it is tied to your
life, liberty,
and pursuit of happiness.
And that for individuals who
are not allowed access to
those fundamental rights,
their lives are really
diminished.
The quality of your life is
greatly diminished by not
having the power to say
"I do" as a grown-up.
It is the most important
decision you make as an adult,
who you choose to spend
your life with.
And Nancy Cott made the argument
that during slavery,
one of the key features, one of
the most important rights
that the slaves wanted was
the right to marry.
Because if you don't have the
full force of the phrase "I
do" as a free person, then you
are not like other people.
And everyone knows it.
One of the things that we
pointed out in our testimony
was how humiliating it can be as
a lesbian or gay person who
wants to marry, to be in the
company of those who can.
They know that you are not an
adult the way that they are.
And that you are viewed as a
second class citizen by people
you work with, by your own
family, by your own children.
And, frankly, people that
are running government.
And it is a very difficult
way to live.
To have people know that
you are not capable
of making that decision.
So what was important about
the case was for so many
experts to come in and show
how it's harmful to us
psychologically, financially,
and in so many ways.
So what was great was even
though the trial itself was
not live streamed like this
talk is right now.
It was captured in
transcripts.
Those transcripts were later
turned into a play called 8.
And we wanted to show you, Alex,
a couple clips from the
play 8, so that you could sort
of get the flavor of what was
happening in the courtroom.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-It's easy for people who want
to deprive gays and lesbians
of their rights to make all
kinds of statements in
campaign literature, or on
TV, where they can't be
cross-examined.
But the witness stand is
a lonely place to lie.
-You cannot say, after the fact,
we are going to take
away the constitutional right
to liberty, privacy,
association that we already
tell you have.
That is not acceptable.
-I am asking you to tell
me how it would harm
opposite sex marriages.
-All right, your honor, my
answer is, I don't know.
-How convinced are you
that you are gay?
-I'm convinced because at 47
years old, I have fallen in
love one time.
It is with Kris.
-We would love to have a family,
but the timeline for
us has always been,
marriage first.
-You two are about the most
responsible, important,
meaningful things I will ever
do in my whole life.
And don't you ever let anyone
ever make you feel any
different, you got it?
-Yes, Mom.
-We put fear and prejudice
on trial.
-The word marriage
has a meaning.
If it wasn't so important, we
wouldn't be here today.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SANDY STIER: So that was just
a brief clip with just a few
little actors that you
may have recognized.
And Jamie Lee Curtis did a
fantastic job playing me.
You probably noticed that
physical resemblance.
That was an amazing thing.
It was actually used as a
fundraiser for the case, which
is great, but also, more
importantly, to really educate
different people and different
audiences about what happened
in that trial.
And to really bring the most
salient points and the most
salient arguments into a kind
of venue where you could
really absorb it.
So this play has been in many,
many colleges, community
colleges, high schools,
community theaters, big, huge
theaters, all over
the country.
And even in different
countries.
And it's great.
It's in Montana, it's in Utah.
It's in wonderful little pockets
of the country that
really need to see this
kind of information.
And we're really grateful that
Lance put this together and
took advantage of the fact
that they wouldn't allow
cameras in the courtroom during
the trial, which is
something that happened
on the very first day.
So moving on, the case timeline
and public opinion.
This is just kind of a brief
graphic of where
the case has been.
We did enter this case
four years ago.
We had a trial in
January of 2011.
Nearly a three week trial.
We won.
We went to appeal.
And we won again.
And then we had a detour at the
California Supreme Court.
And finally ended up
in the federal
Supreme Court in March.
And now, of course, we're
waiting for a ruling and, as
you can see, public opinion
has gone nowhere but up,
really, in terms of supporting
gay marriage since we began
this process.
KRIS PERRY: So we wanted to show
you one other video clip
of some of the actual people,
not the actors that played
people in the trial, which was
a way of taking you back four
years and showing you some of
the exciting things that
happened in the courtroom.
And why we won.
So many witnesses, so much
powerful testimony.
But now, you have the
combination of not only that,
but the shift in public opinion
combined with what
happened in the courtroom.
And now all culminating in what
we hope will be a very
positive ruling next week.
So when we went to Washington DC
a couple of months ago for
the hearing to watch Ted Olson
and others argue this case, we
were accompanied
by many others.
So we'll show you a little
bit about what
happened on that day.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Well, here it is, the day
before we go to the Supreme
Court to hear Ted Olson, and
the Solicitor General argue
our case in front of
the Supreme Court.
So today, in order to get ready,
we're going to going to
the National Archives to see the
US Constitution, which is
a huge highlight for both Sandy
and I and our kids.
We're definitely excited
to be here.
We're proud to be here.
We're certainly nervous.
Cautiously optimistic, but most
importantly, we're hopeful.
-Right, now, we're just
preparing for the argument.
And it's to go through and make
sure that we have every
possible question, every
possible argument the other
side can come up with and we've
done as much as we can
to prepare and respond
to those.
-When we set up four years ago,
we said we were going to
make this case before
the Supreme Court.
Before the highest court
in the land.
And I think we're all going to
be just in awe to watch Ted
Olson up there making
our case.
-It's a dialogue among
the justices.
They use their questions to
explore issues, so you can't
read too much into anything.
-We think history will look back
and feel proud that our
country came together to support
equality for all
people and we're just so
grateful that we get to be a
part of this very important
civil rights issue.
-We're Kris and Sandy's sons,
so we just tag along for the
ride and try to make
them look good.
I think Elliott and I are
immensely proud of our moms
and what they're doing.
-Tomorrow morning, we'll get up
very early and we will make
our way to the Supreme Court.
Sounds strange even saying
it out loud.
-We have great clients.
They are in love.
They want to get married.
This is a defining civil
rights issue of our
generation.
It is a time that I
think we advance
the agenda of equality.
Not just for gays and lesbians,
but for everybody.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-It's freezing, but,
of course, I'm so
excited to be here.
-We've been on the case for a
very, very long time and it's
a great journey.
And we've accomplished
a lot so far.
-I'm trying to wrap my head
around the fact that this is
actually real and happening.
And that we're here, but it's
incredibly exciting and
historic morning.
-This is exactly what our
judicial system is for.
And this is where we should
be on this day.
-A lot of people have made
this possible by their
generous support.
And we want to thank them and
really want and thank the
millions of people around the
country that have worked so
hard to make this possible.
-To me, all of this work,
everything that we're doing,
is about the next generation.
So that the young people out
there who are just coming of
age, falling in love for
the first time, they
do so without judgment.
-I know what I'm going to
be seeing from our side.
Ted Olson is going to be
brilliant, as he always is.
And he will make the points
that we feel necessary.
[APPLAUSE]
-It's incredible.
It's a historic day.
For the LGBT rights movement.
-I'm already very anxiously
waiting for June.
I'm already nervous, I'm like,
OK, do they have it yet?
Did they decide it?
And it's only been
ten minutes.
-It's a little bit of a relief,
but at the same time,
now we wait.
And we know we have to wait
for three months before we
find out what they've decided.
-The most important battle, I
think, clearly has been won.
The one thing thought about in
there was again, sitting in
the back of Harvey's old camera
store on Castro Street
and Harvey saying, you've
got to come out.
And it's pretty extraordinary.
DUSTIN LANCE BLACK: We're
not done in this
movement for LGBT equality.
So next is get back to work and
keep fighting to make sure
the next generation's lives
are better than ours.
I think that's our
job as Americans.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KRIS PERRY: So I mentioned the
way public opinion has shifted
over the last four years and
this is just a way of showing
you how many polls
have been done.
Very reputable, national polls,
over the four year
period and how great
this trend is.
This is a great trend line
for us, for any movement.
Moving on to the next slide,
showing you a little bit about
how the country is shifting,
in terms of legalizing
marriage equality.
You can see which states--
the dark blue states--
do have it already.
Blue states, the light
blue, are obviously
working toward it.
And the gray is all the work
we still have to do.
Because as exciting as it is
to have New England and
Western states, taking a hard
look at this, look at what's
happening in the middle of the
country and in the south.
There's a lot of work to do.
So, Sandy, you're the
legal expert.
[LAUGHTER]
SANDY STIER: That's right.
I'm so glad to be recognized
for what I really am.
After being in the trial for
three weeks, you feel like a
legal expert.
I actually felt like
I got a master's
degree in marriage equality.
It's fantastic.
So what could the court
decide to do?
Well, they could decide to do
the brave thing, which is to
rule on the merits
of the case.
That's what we hope they do.
And really on the merit
of the case would
be a 50 state ruling.
It's what we hope
fervently for.
It's a big ask.
It's a big win.
And we think it's it would be
an amazing thing to have.
But there are different
options of what
could actually happen.
They could uphold Proposition 8,
they could decline to rule,
and they could, well,
there's another one
that'll pop up in a second.
They could strike down
Proposition 8.
So if they strike down
Proposition 8, we can win a
couple of different ways.
The A is the merits ruling.
We could also win on standing.
which just means the proponents
didn't have
standing to bring the
case the court.
They could also just dismiss
the case, which is somewhat
unlikely, and would have a
similar impact as standing.
Which is basically that
California would have marriage
equality and potentially the
states that, depending on how
the ruling is written,
potentially the states that
had domestic partnerships.
If they uphold Proposition 8,
that is, of course, the worst
thing that could happen.
That means we roll
back the clock.
So those are the options.
That's my very in-depth legal
analysis on the topic.
And for more information, we
have a brilliant lawyer right
here who can answer any question
that you have.
KRIS PERRY: That wraps up the
part of the presentation where
we have pictures and
videos to show you.
And now we would like to
just interact with you.
So if the lights could come up
and we could just have a
conversation about the things
that you may be wanting to ask
that are somewhat complicated
and a little bit arcane.
Because we showed you three
possible outcomes, but if you
start talking to anybody that's
a legal expert, they'll
tell you there are dozens
of possible outcomes.
And not to mention how
many different days
this could all occur.
Right now, we think the one day
they're supposed to meet
is Monday, but everyone says
they can't do all the cases
they have in one day, so
it'll be adding days.
So we have lots to look forward
to next week and we
would really love to just talk
to you about your questions
and thoughts about this.
ALEX: What is next week going
to look like for you?
So once the decision's handed
down, what are you guys going
to be doing?
And then second part to that
question, is after next week,
what is your political life
going to look like?
How are you going to
continue to be
politically engaged in this?
Are you going to take a break?
Which would be OK, too, because
you've done a lot of
work for us already.
But what are your thoughts
on that going forward?
SANDY STIER: Well, we think we
are probably going to stop
suing people, first of all.
We've learned that lawsuits are
long and expensive ways to
resolve problems.
So we'll let that go for a
while, but we will always
fight certainly for
equal rights.
Now what would really help--
we'll be in DC next week.
So we're going Sunday in
anticipation of the possible
ruling Monday.
If not Monday, and they add
additional days, it could be
Wednesday or Thursday.
We really hope to be at the
Supreme Court, ideally inside,
and hear the decision
being read.
And we're really hoping that we
have something very special
to celebrate.
So we'd celebrate with our legal
team, and many of the
founders of the case, and of
course each other, and the
other plaintiffs.
And then we'd become fairly
involved in some of the media
that will happen as a result
of the ruling.
And its a wild and crazy
week for us.
And honestly, then we go right
back to our normal lives.
Getting kids up and making them
go to their summer jobs.
And all that kind of stuff.
And go to jobs ourselves.
But we do really feel very, very
hopeful that we're going
to have a positive outcome.
It's just a matter of how big.
How big.
And so, we're full
of anticipation.
KRIS PERRY: The future political
work, oddly enough,
we don't see this as a
political activity.
I know that may strike
some of you as odd.
It just feels like an extension
of our personal of
disagreement with the
law, Proposition 8.
And one way of resolving
that disagreement
was to go to court.
And then we didn't take
a political path to
resolve this problem.
And others may.
If there's a very bad outcome--
in other words,
Proposition 8 continues
to exist--
people are already talking.
Political people are already
talking about what they'll do
about that.
But that's their job.
They're full-time politicians.
That's what they do
for a living.
Or there are voters out there
that may come together and
decide they want to do
something about it,
as a group of voters.
But that was not really
our method.
We think that that actually
isn't the kind of permanent
solution this deserves.
Other kinds of problems that
exist for lesbian and gay
individuals and couples are
going to continue to happen.
We see already within the
immigration reform debate, how
much the gay couple,
international couple issue has
emerged as a sticking point
for some people.
We know recently HUD released
a study that shows that
lesbian and gay couples are
discriminated against in their
pursuit of housing.
There are other problems still
that exist around bullying and
even the way the K-12 education
world is viewing
whether or not to
teach kids about
different kind of families.
It's a really pervasive problem
to get people to
recognize that lesbian and gay
people, and couples, and
families, and kids are equal.
Equal.
Not less than.
Not better than.
Equal.
And that will be, frankly,
something we'll probably have
to tackle our whole lives
because we're
getting rather old.
There's not that
much time left.
SANDY STIER: I'm getting
pretty old.
KRIS PERRY: You're pretty old.
[LAUGHTER]
KRIS PERRY: There's
a lot to do.
ALEX: And one more question
before opening it up.
I want to kind of step back.
So gay marriage has been kind of
the headliner issue in the
civil rights advocacy
in our community.
And I think it's galvanized
a lot of people.
It's united people within the
gay community and also our
allies, in a way that's been
really great to see.
And as we saw with the map,
the struggle is going to
continue unless the Supreme
Court goes big.
How do you think we can maintain
that unity and
leverage it?
In addressing these
other issues?
There are also major
LGBT health issues.
Very little research has been
done about the different
health challenges that our
particular communities face.
So that you can't even design
health programs or medical
care in a way that suits us
best, because there's really
no research and no knowledge
around it.
Around domestic violence, sexual
violence, bullying,
things like that.
Do you have any thoughts about
how we can maintain that unity
going forward?
KRIS PERRY: I think what--
we were having a great
conversation with Enrique
before we started, where really,
the lesbian and gay
community is the most perfect
example of such a cross
section of the country
as a group.
So unlike any other minority
groups, you are different from
your family.
And so we have to create that.
We have to create family.
And one way that happens is
we're really diverse.
Every racial group, both
genders, all kinds of
different sexual orientation,
decisions, as well as
socioeconomic, people dealing
with different health issues.
We are full blown cross
section of the
country, of the world.
And in some ways, we are
instructive to other groups
that are dealing with issues,
some of which you named, as a
way to come together
as a coalition.
And what was most probably
catalytic and interesting
about this case was
a bipartisan
approach to a problem.
Which, right now, seems to be
one of the hardest things for
people to do in this country
is to come together across
party lines, but frankly, that's
not the only way to
solve problems.
And I think what's been really
helpful for Sandy and I is to
see ourselves as part of this
really big quilt of people and
different approaches.
And I think if we could take
that whole group and keep
moving forward to solve new
problems together, we'll solve
more problems together.
AUDIENCE: I, probably like
many of us, had kind of a
civics high school view
of the Supreme Court.
Stone building with
guys in robes.
But a bunch of us at Google
sat and listened to the
transcripts together in a room,
like the moment they
were released.
And I know, for me, there was
this sudden like, wait a
minute, this isn't abstract,
this is about me.
So I'm wondering like if that
happened to me, what happened
to you, personally, sitting
in the Supreme Court?
Did that change your view
of the Supreme Court?
Or of process?
Or of what it means?
SANDY STIER: You know, it did.
Really.
It's fascinating being in the
Supreme Court and to see the
energy of others trying to get
to the court, as well.
For four days, there were people
camping out trying to
get those very few public
spots in the court.
And it was snowing.
It was a rough time.
But to go into the courtroom,
it's very highly structured.
There's a lot of security and
it's a very formal way of
entering the courtroom.
We weren't seated with the other
plaintiffs or anybody in
our team, necessarily.
We're just seated in the general
audience, but Kris and
I were fortunate so we
could sit together.
It was actually a
little bit hard.
But being in the courtroom, it's
an intimate environment.
I don't know if you've
ever been into the
Supreme Court before.
It's of course available
for public tour.
But it's not a huge courtroom.
It's a fairly small courtroom.
Very grand.
Very beautiful.
But from any place that you're
sitting, you feel like you
could really see the justices.
You can see the look
on their face.
And we had fairly good
seats, actually.
We were towards the front,
and towards the middle.
And you could really view
their expression as they
spoke, or as they had an
emotional response to what
somebody else on
the bench said.
And I guess I always knew that
just from the lawyers telling
us how the court works, it's
a one hour hearing.
We knew that, of course.
And then our side only had 30
minutes and out of our 30
minutes, we had 10 minutes
that would be used by the
Solicitor General for
the White House,
which is a good thing.
But Ted Olson had 20 minutes
to make his argument.
That's a very short
amount of time.
And he was into about the
first sentence of his
argument, when he was
immediately interrupted by one
of the justices.
And that's how the
whole thing goes.
So regardless of what beautiful
thing you've planned
to say, it will be
interrupted.
And then you'll immediately be
responding to questions.
And so the justices immediately
took them down
into the path of standing--
around the issue of standing--
as they did with Charles Cooper,
the lead attorney on
the other side, as well.
And we spent a lot of
time on standing.
I didn't expect that.
And that was a little
disconcerting, actually.
Because we kept thinking, let's
talk about the merits,
let's talk about the most
important things, let's talk
about equal protection.
We don't want to talk about
standing for too long, because
we don't want to miss the most
important points that Ted is
going to make today.
So that was one thing, that
the justices really
orchestrate the courtroom.
And the Chief Justice
really is clearly in
charge of the courtroom.
And then some of the comments
the justices made.
If you listen to them, you might
have a similar reaction.
I found them curious
or puzzling.
And more than I expected to.
I thought it would
be more judicial.
More television-like
or something.
But they really went down some
paths that were very
unexpected.
And their comments
were unexpected.
And that was definitely
a twist.
What was your response to it?
KRIS PERRY: I think you
covered everything.
SANDY STIER: I probably did.
KRIS PERRY: Quite an
exhaustively very
comprehensive answer.
Yes.
Congratulations.
[LAUGHTER]
KRIS PERRY: It was odd to be
there as a lesbian asking nine
Supreme Court justices to
protect me from a law in the
state that I love, because
it was really harming me.
And for all of you that
listened, I hope that you
could feel the importance of the
moment, versus the words.
Because it was a moment.
And the courtroom was
just electric.
It was packed.
It was shoulder to shoulder.
Members of Congress, members of
White House administration,
public, lawyers from the Supreme
Court Bar all packed
in there together, anxiously
awaiting
to hear these arguments.
And to understand.
And to be a part of
a historic moment.
And it really was a historic
moment that I'm very, very
honored to have even been
in the courtroom at all.
SANDY STIER: And there were
moments when justices said
things that you so
appreciated.
Like when Breyer said,
what about the kids?
I mean Kennedy.
What about the kids
that are here?
That's the legal
analysis part.
We have to be a voice
for them, as well.
How do they get represented?
And it was heart-warming to
see that somebody thought
about that part, as well.
Because that's one of the
things that has really
compelled us to be involved in
this case is it's really not
just about us-- we're in pretty
good shape in our
lives-- but we really
care about the
generations coming up.
And we want that to be
acknowledged in the
courtroom, as well.
ALEX: OK, so this other question
was that opponents
often use the argument that are
based on this detrimental
effects of same sex marriage
on children.
And the question was what you
guys thought about that?
And why that argument
seems to have such
traction or not at all?
KRIS PERRY: Well, the thing
that definitely happened
around Proposition 8 is they
used this idea that you should
be afraid of lesbian and gay
people as a campaign strategy.
It was part of the campaign
rhetoric.
And it was highly effective.
I don't know if you can
remember back to the
Proposition 8 ads, but they
often had children in them and
their parents talking to them
about, it's scary now that
you're going to school
and you're
learning about these families.
Or it's scary to us, as parents,
that you may end up
marrying someone of
the same sex.
So they used it very prominently
in the campaign,
Proposition 8.
And they did something
really effective.
They created a problem in their
campaign called, gay
people are scary.
And then they created a solution
called, don't let
them get married.
And it was just effective
enough that they won.
Now, in court, there were
attempts made to repeat some
of those statements, but they
didn't hold up in the
courtroom because they didn't
have witnesses who could
support that, as
you point out.
So the judge was patient,
really, for them to just
describe what they wanted
to say about that.
But was not as patient when
they couldn't produce an
expert witness to support
it with data.
Our side, on the other hand,
had multiple witnesses that
had done long term studies
on a large samples.
Of either adults that were
gay, or just the average
person, that didn't support
that at all.
So the reason it lives
on, I think, is a
question for all of us.
Where does that come from?
What institution is promulgating
this believe that
lesbian and gay people are
harmful for children?
Don't protect children?
There are lots of other were
negative terms that people use
to describe lesbian
and gay people in
relationship to children.
And it's not supported
by evidence.
So what we hope is that if
marriage equality starts to
occur, that we'll be able to,
over time, demonstrate through
our actions.
And the way that we live.
And the way we parent that these
things will no longer
hold up, in and that those
beliefs will slowly
diminished.
But it will take a
really long time.
Like I said, we probably won't
be alive when it stops being.
SANDY STIER: That's
kind of a bummer.
KRIS PERRY: These things
take generations,
unfortunately, to unwind.
Homophobia has been a
longstanding problem and it's
not going to disappear even
with a really promising
ruling, unfortunately.
AUDIENCE: I was in a room
many years ago, Meet in
the Middle in Fresno.
And it was like a war.
Room we all had the
same outcome.
We wanted marriage equality,
but so many different
paths to get there.
And nobody could really
come up with sort of a
common way to do it.
And then this happened.
And it was like out
of right field.
A few people have decided this
was the right course.
And I'm curious, using that sort
of success, and how that
was determined, how do we apply
that to these other
problems that you're
describing?
That are going to continue.
Do we wait, as leaders,
for sort of a common
decision to be made?
Or do we learn from this and
just go for what we think
individually as a small group
is the right thing to do?
SANDY STIER: One of the most
important contributors to the
success of this particular
strategy was really a pulling
together some of the best
and the brightest.
I mean Ted Olson, David Boies,
they are absolutely the best
and brightest among
constitutional lawyers.
With a great deal of experience
with the Supreme Court.
So that's very, very
important.
And we really had the solid
initial backing of enough
funders from different parts,
different political parties
that are across the board that
they could give it the boost
it needed to get
the case going.
So for us, I think, it was an
unusual mix to have that
strength early on.
And it certainly contributed
to the success.
I think Kris pointed out
something really important
earlier, which is the bipartisan
method is very,
very important.
And Ted and David leading
our case is such a
great example of that.
They come from two very
different parties and yet,
they immediately took it out of
that world and said, this
is not about politics, this
is about equal rights.
Has nothing to do
with politics.
And I think that was a
successful strategy, as well,
because then you get more people
on board, more people
supporting it.
And I would hope that we can
address a lot of the issues
that we're looking at
in a similar way.
Whether they're gay rights
issues or other civil rights
issues, like education
or health care.
These are human fundamental
rights and we don't want them
to be partisan rights,
if at all possible.
Or partisanship involved
in it.
KRIS PERRY: The common
denominator is leadership.
I honestly believe whatever
problem you're trying to
solve, you need to
be a leader.
You have to take risk, you
have to be passionate and
single minded about your goal.
And you can't give up.
You cannot give up.
Everybody here will come
across some bridge.
You have to lead other
people across it.
What's really interesting about
the people that stand
out in this case is every single
person to a person is a
leader in their own right.
And yet there are so many
involved in this at one time.
You mentioned the example of
you're working hard to create
some push-back on a political
front, because
it was a voter mandate.
And you're trying to figure out
how to unvote it, right?
Well, guess what, somebody was
a leader in another room and
thought there was a different
way to move ahead and he led a
group of people down
that road.
And that is the key ingredient
to change.
Is leadership.
And I really can't encourage
you enough to find your
problem and solve it.
And be the leader on it.
And you'll end up doing
something that may not be the
thing that won, but
you contributed to
a win, either way.
AUDIENCE: Could you speak a
little as to your efforts for
education for younger kids?
KRIS PERRY: I will.
There's a question about
what I'm working on
around early education.
I happen to know that you have
a really high quality early
learning center here
at Google.
I'd really love to
see it if anybody
could run me over there.
But what I've been working on in
my career for 25 years has
been advocating for children.
Particularly children under
the age of five.
Because just like the marriage
equality fight and using data
and evidence to prove that is
no longer acceptable to
exclude a group of people from
a fundamental institution.
There are a group of kids in
this country who are being
excluded from the education
system.
And it is affecting the
trajectory of their entire
life, in ways that are
very, very harmful.
And it's very much
based on economic
factors and that is all.
So what the president has done
and around marriage equality
and early learning is say, in
order for our country to be
strong and for us to be
together, we need to be
educated, and we need to
stop discriminating
against groups of people.
And I feel like that is a common
theme in both efforts.
Early learning is based on the
fact that most of us, almost
everybody, gains 90% of their
brain weight before they turn
3 and the synaptic connections
that are happening are
happening most rapidly then.
And unfortunately, by
the time you turn 5,
they start to prune.
Your brain is pruning.
So that's why we all have memory
problems later in life.
You probably don't at Google,
but the rest of us do.
Because the truth is, those
pathways are used later on for
high level executive function,
analytical skills, that allow
you to have really great
jobs like you all have.
Or to work on hard issues
like we're working on.
You have to have a lot of
capacity, honestly, to deal
with so much that comes after
you in this world, today.
So early learning and, for me,
early learning and marriage
equality are very similar in
the sense that they really
help people reach
their potential.
And not be inhibited.
Or told that they're not going
to be successful or going to
be a good person.
And it's fun to work on both.
And I keep working on the other
thing because that's the
job I have.
Sandy is a health care
technology systems director,
which also, I think, really is
intended to help people have
access to something
they need to be.
ALEX: So maybe just to close
out as a final question.
You've talked about this
a little bit already.
But what can people
in this room do?
And now I'm going to
ask a bad question.
What's our obligation?
So what is our obligation
either as a member of a
minority class or group to help
broaden inequality for
other people in my group or
other minority groups?
Or for potential allies?
What kind of obligations
do we have?
And how should we
execute them?
SANDY STIER: We should have lots
and lots of children, if
at all possible.
Because we need the
data on parenting.
And do not mess your kids up.
I'm not saying that we didn't
mess our kids up.
We tried.
ALEX: Just do your best.
SANDY STIER: That's right,
do your best.
I think on some level, Cleve
Jones always quotes Harvey
Milk in his quote that
you heard, come out,
come out, be honest.
And I think that's really one
easy thing that we are
obligated to do.
Be honest.
Don't hide yourself.
Talk about difficult issues.
Keep talking to relatives
at old school
and all those people.
And help them make the
switch slowly.
We've really seen, with the
public opinion shifted, we've
seen it certainly
in the polls.
We've also seen in the people
that we love and care about,
our families and friends.
That people come to
things slowly.
Like Obama came to
it slowly, right?
But that has to be OK.
You have to give people
a chance to change
and be OK with it.
And not hold it against
them too much that
it took a long time.
Or that's its happening
slowly.
But I think supporting change
is the best way to model the
future that we want to have
for our own kids.
We want them to feel comfortable
coming out, then
be comfortable being out.
Right?
And if we can do that that's
something everybody can do.
KRIS PERRY: I think you
live with a lot of
integrity and passion.
And be a model.
Model what you think we
should all be doing,
wherever you are.
And it can be on a very small,
one-on-one basis with somebody.
It does not have to be on the
scale of the United States
Supreme Court.
I think it's actually the
smaller interactions that
happened between individuals
at work.
One-on-one at a family
reunion.
At a class reunion.
Even at the doctor's office
when you have to tell them
their form's wrong.
Those interactions actually
do change the world.
They add up to something that's
cumulatively powerful.
And on behalf of Sandy and I
want to thank you for letting
us tell you about our
contribution to this gigantic
effort that we're all
really engaged in.
You wouldn't be here if you
didn't care a lot about it and
you were out there advocating
yourself.
I'm sure you are.
And we need all of our voices
singing in unison on this
issue of fairness and equality
because the more diverse and
inclusive we are, the
stronger we are.
So thank you for
having us here.
ALEX: And we just want to thank
you so much for your
leadership over the years.
I mean this takes a toll and
personally, time-wise,
financially, all of that.
And civil rights movement, as
you said, are just built over
generations, over decades, and
everyone adds a little bit.
And you guys have clearly added
a huge block to it.
And so, hopefully, we'll all
kind of take that and continue
to move forward with you guys.
And also I think you guys are
clearly very articulate and
inspirational.
So I think the other thing that
you guys have brought is
probably just inspiring
thousands of others to
advocate for whatever equality
that they feel is important,
in their own way.
So thank you very much
for everything.
[APPLAUSE]